[Musik]
da quake keine ruhe eine sicherung keine
ruhe ohne sicherung danke das habe ich
jetzt nicht grund sehen aber deswegen
kann er dort zu trainieren
der truppenübungsplatz allentsteig in
niederösterreich
ich bin hier mit dem er 5 der
österreichischen luftstreitkräfte
verabredet in 15 sekunden müssen da sein
nein danke
der traum vom fliegen viele junge
österreicherinnen und österreicher
würden gern pilot hatte laut werden wenn
man fliegen will ist das eine option
unsere auswahlkriterien sonst war sehr
streng aber wer das geschafft hat
bekommt erstens auf fantastische
ausbildung und dann sehr interessanten
sehr spannenden sehr abwechslungsreichen
beruf für alle die sich jetzt passiert
der technik und die verschiedenen typen
von hubschraubern und flugzeugen
interessieren was haben wir denn wir
haben eine beachtliche hubschrauberpilot
für immerhin 66 glück wenn man von den
kleinen beginnen
dezember sondern der flexibus das gerät
und das einzige gerät die 212 von blekko
kann unser schweres transportgerät und
diallo 32 jahren relativ alt aber auch
sehr verlässliches system und bis heute
umstellung beim hoch gebildet
na ja noch nicht ganz es fehlt noch ein
gewisses boden training am boden
training ja bewusst über worden bastler
hit zu zeitig leicht
renovierungsbedürftig herzlich
willkommen beim serie training des
österreichischen bundesheeres befreien
aus ansteckung mit irgendwas man hört
dabei arzt robert du hast glaube eine
büroklammer einstieg fuchs wenn ganz
genau warum das jetzt alles her zeigen
dass das ganze aber prinzipiell macht
diesen gebieten mit dem finger auf
kontakt
also ich hab die entscheidung jetzt
gelöst oder zumindest irgendwie jetzt
bin ich aber dummerweise gefangenen im
raum wo ich nur aus dem fenster flüchten
kann ich habe nicht gewusst dass man
sich einen garten abzählen kann aber er
wird das mehr vorzeigen
ok jetzt holt er leiter und ich kann
dann auch und ich haben gefährden ein
feuerwehrschlauch entschieden
[Musik]
wo beginnt jetzt verflucht parcours für
euch jetzt jetzt viele stationen
praktisch geübt doch was man alles
zusammen dass der gefällt mir ist
wichtig dass ihr gefechts minister
vorgesetzt leise der sieg hat sich
gegenseitig und gemacht so schnell als
möglich und kunstfreiheit los
[Musik]
erster teil des serie trainings wir
sehen das gebäude raus und landen wie
sich so was gehört im grünen
und das sieht man schon genau richtig
für den zweiten teil aber habe mir
gesagt hier in grünen finde ich unfair
sichtlicher antwort
so wird ich darf dich herzlich
willkommen heißen wer eine ausbildung
der frischen luft bei kräfte bei der sie
ihre ausbildung ist eine abkürzung für
survival evasion resistance und das ist
natürlich vor allem zum beispiel wichtig
für die österreichische luftverkehrs der
fall schon mal irgendwas passieren soll
dazu hätte ich schon eine ausrüstung für
die vorbereitet so genannte überlebens
wester okay das ist alles drin ein
personalpaket anbieten
taschenlampen fußsohle sprich kompasse
eine kleine erste hilfe ausrüstung und
eine sogenannte überlebensgroße das
hätte ich bitten darf mir zu folgen
das ist eine meiner ausbildung sind bei
der ersten station
ja die stadt schon vorher machen man hat
in der überlebens dose verschiedene
sachen drinnen was ist hier einen key
sparen das ist ein sehr hartes holz und
benötigt ein messer und einen feuerstein
also ich wo er mit dem messer lebt eine
kleine mulde wieder von silvias schlägt
der vorstadt funken
[Musik]
das freut uns ja dein nächstes bedürfnis
was kannst du dir vorstellen wäre höchst
häuser unter wasser
es gibt auf der einen seite wasser des
integrations tabletten und und einer
busse trainer hast es gibt auch etwas
anderes kaliber man genauso gut zum
wasser desinfizieren genügt eine kleine
messerspitze ja wohl perfekt lange noch
und das was sie eben zu machen schütteln
kurz warten und das ist
[Musik]
das nächste auf deiner wirst du warst du
gerne haben wir das in der natur besser
gehen wieder zurück zur super fehlen uns
noch irgendwie einlage august gesammelt
als ja nur die besten sachen wir haben
da weniger blätter die samen vom
breitwegerich und die blätter von
bradley gerichtet zu haben oder zusammen
wo die brennstoff- und dann muss ich
natürlich aus kennen das sie haben wir
auch alles in der ausbildung kann ist
genau der falsche wasser brauchen ja
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist soweit kein comic
preis wenn man entgegen dafür aber so
misst damit das ok hab gedanken ich habe
gegessen ich habe mich aufgewärmt jetzt
minimiert somit suchen wir uns einen
platz
der war schlecht einsichtig ist da und
natürlich im wald bietet sich an sehr
recht ok damit direkt ihnen gehen sehen
wir eine wunderbare spur wo spürhunde
derzeit darum sofort finden würden okay
ich mache einen sogenannten fisch passen
ja richtig das hat diesen sinn wenn
jetzt der hunde und uns jahr sind in dem
versteck sind werden die hunde genau uns
hier nachgehen ja und vom versteck aus
werden wir die hunde sehen
ich habe sie schon vorbereitet richtig
wäre hat sich von oben nicht gesehen
diese unterkunft es relativ schnell
gebaut es ist nichts andere fast wie ein
regenponcho es riecht auch gut so hast
du eigentlich überlebt er ist ein
trinken mutter kommt kann es sein dass
anfang rechten sind dazu musst du dich
so gut wie es geht und sichtbar machen
ich habe etwas für dich
sehr gut sind richtig auf die
nasenspitze in china bisher die uhren
sind auch überstehen geworden sind
überhaupt wo er steht in seinem kopf und
liebe grüße
alles gute kommt von oben in diesem fall
die rettung wie so eine rettung aus der
luft ausschaut wir schauen uns gemeinsam
an
[Musik]